[Musique]
pour remonter sur scène après un an sans
concert et en plus pour le plus grand
festival de france
de quoi avoir un peu le trac mais pas
d'inquiétude
maya kamati est là et elle est en pleine
forme
[Musique]
avec pendill et la réunionnaise ouvre le
bal des vieilles charrues
un festival en jauge réduite qu'ovide
oblige mais un bel honneur pour
l'artiste et pour son île de la réunion
ouvrir un tel festival avec une artiste
qui chante en créole en majorité c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment le donnait enfin
c'est avoir confiance c'est nous donner
beaucoup de de bain de résonance c'est
un gros point que d'attaquer cette ce
festival est d'ouvrir d'avoir l'honneur
d'ouvrir ce festival est bon ça va être
génial ça être un bon moment et prénom
on est parent est entouré d'une toute
nouvelle équipe de musiciens mahdia
kamati balaye la pluie la boue et le
froid breton en musique on décolle pour
la réunion au rythme du kayamb revisité
version électro
[Musique]
on est ravi et l'océan indien encore
plus voilà c'est le raciste mes racines
moi et ma fille ça fait toujours chaud
au coeur de trouver la musique de là bas
de belles découvertes je ne connaissais
pas du tout et voilà j'ai appris que
c'était la réunion de famille un peu de
chaleur du soleil beaucoup de mouvance
beaucoup de groupes beaucoup de vrais
pêche quoi est ce ce qu'on aime
pari réussi la tournée est bien lancé
maya kamati peut repartir sur les routes
avec sa musique qui transporte et qui
transperce jusqu'au bouquet final à la
réunion d'ici la fin de l'été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]